hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
with the IBM cloud team today we want to
talk about operators and now I'm not
actually talking about operations teams
but instead the operators framework
which can be used on kubernetes or
OpenShift
core OS actually introduced the operator
framework back in 2016
Korra's is now a part of Red Hat and IBM
operator framework is quickly picking up
traction as it's a great way of managing
complex kubernetes applications now
before I jump into this we want to
actually introduce what the kubernetes
control loop is because it's a core part
of the operators framework in this video
we're going to be talking about things
like deployments and pods so if you're
not familiar with those be sure to check
out the kubernetes explained video that
i've done on those topics but let's get
started with exactly what the control
loop is in kubernetes now essentially
the way it starts the control loop is
the core part of kubernetes it observes
the state of what's in your actual
cluster so that's the first step
observe next what it's going to do
kubernetes is going to double check that
the state in the actual cluster versus
the state that you want it to be so it's
going to do a diff and finally it wants
to resolve that diff by acting on it so
the last phase of the control loop is
act now the control loop is core to how
kubernetes works and there's a
controller that basically acts on that
for every default resource kubernetes
comes with a number of default resources
let's see an example of deploying an
application without operators using
these default resources so as an end
user essentially the first thing you're
going to want to do is write up some
gamal write the spec for that actual
application and for our particular
example let's say that you know we're
doing a deployment and in this
deployment
we'll have to define some configuration
things like what's the image and maybe
the replicas
and maybe some other configuration so
that's one kubernetes resource and
essentially what you would do is take
that and deploy it into your kubernetes
cluster at which point a deployment is
made here's where the control loop kicks
in so kubernetes observes the state of
your cluster so we've got a kubernetes
cluster here and checks what's the
difference between what you want or
what's there first thing it notices
there's no pods so it's gonna act on
that difference and it's gonna create
some pods now let's say for fairly
complex application we don't just have
one yamo but we have a second llamo
maybe it's for the backend and so that
deploys and second deployment and that
in turn deploys a pod using the
controllers in the control loop now it's
a simple example but say you want to go
through here scale up the application
make some changes set up some secrets
environment variables every single time
you have to either create new kubernetes
resources or go in here and edit the
existing ones that can start to get
fairly difficult now let's see how
that's done in a world where we're using
operators now the first thing you would
actually need to do is install the
operator itself so someone in your team
has to create the operator or maybe you
can use one of the many that are out
there on operator hub or the community
is building on the operators that are
available so the first thing you need in
your kubernetes cluster is the OLM which
is the operator lifecycle manager which
basically manages two operators that you
have installed next you deploy your
actual operator into the cluster the
operator is made up of two major
components the first component and
operator is going to be the CR D the
other one is going to be the controller
now the CR D is basically a custom
resource definition so we've talked
about default resources things like
deployments and pods a custom resource
is something that you define as a user
in kubernetes or maybe an operator
defines it so that you can create yam
to work against that that custom config
the controller is basically a custom
control loop which runs as a pod in your
cluster and runs this control loop
against your custom resource definition
so let's say that the operator and
operator is created for our custom
application deployment here so instead
of having to write multiple deployments
and setting up config maps and secrets
for whatever our cluster needs we
instead as an end user here we'll
instead actually just deploy one yeah
Mille
maybe we called this operator my app it
could be a little bit more meaningful
here we can call it stateful app
front-end app whatever we want it to be
and then we could define some config
here or we can use the defaults that are
set kind of have a choice of options
here then we take this operator and we
deploy it directly into the cluster at
this point the operator takes over and
this is actually responsible for running
that control loop and figuring out
exactly what needs to be running so it's
going to realize that we need a couple
of deployments and the pods now this is
a kind of a format over approach to
managing applications that's inherently
easier and scales better than this
approach because as an end-user you
really only have to worry about the
config that's been exposed to you and
the operator itself manages the control
loop and the state of the application
how it needs to look now there's great
operators out there already things like
managing at CD or various databases or
even IBM cloud services so all of those
operators currently exist on the
operator hub but say you want to develop
your own maybe a custom operator for
something that is native to your
application architecture kind of like
what we sketched out here well there's a
number of ways you can do that and
there's something called operator SDK
that allows you to start building out
operators yourself now I'd say the
easiest way to get started with an
operator is to use the helm one
so helm as you may already know there is
a video that where David o kun goes over
exactly how hum works
be sure to check that one out but the
helm approach allows you to take a
helmet and apply that towards an
operator expose config so it allows you
to get to a fairly mature level of an
operator kind of something like this for
a chart that's already there now the
maturity of operators what I've sketched
out down here falls into five different
levels
now helm actually hits the first two
levels of maturity let's talk about what
those levels are the first one it's
basic install essentially the first
level is basically going to allow you to
do just provisioning of the resources
required now the second phase goes a
little bit further it's gonna allow you
to do upgrades so this supports minor
and patch version upgrades to whatever
is defined in your operator now helm
gets you that far what about for the for
the next three levels of maturity for
these you're gonna want to use either go
or you can also use ansible now these
will allow you to actually get to all
five levels of maturity with operators
let's quickly talk about what those are
at the third level we've got full
lifecycle support so this is storage
lifecycle app lifecycle it's also going
to allow you to do things like backup
and failure recovery so that's something
that would be kind of configured and
developed into the operator who ever
developed that one fourth what we've got
here is insights this is going to allow
you to get deep metrics and analysis
logging that kind of thing from your
actual operator and finally what we have
is something called autopilot and just
kind of how it sounds this is going to
have a lot more functionality built into
operator itself basically it's going to
allow you to do automatic scaling
horizontal and vertically
it's going to do automatic config tuning
if your operator based app gets into a
bad state it's gonna identify that
automatically so these are kind of five
levels of maturity that operators can
have by looking on operator hub you can
see the ones that the community has
developed and see what level of maturity
that they hit and then again by using
operator SDK you can build your own
operators using either helm go or
ansible thanks for joining me for this
video on operators if you have any
questions be sure to drop us a line
below if you want to see more videos
like this in the future please like and
subscribe and don't forget you can
always get started on the cloud at no
cost by signing up for a free IVM cloud
account